if you're experiencing symptoms like a
runny nose
watery eyes constantly clearing your
throat like me you are not alone
southwest medical wants to make sure you
have the proper information and
treatment you need
to get through those pesky seasonal
allergies take a look
so we're talking about asthma and
allergy awareness something very
important for people to understand and
know about
um let's start off with the basics what
are the most common allergies right here
in southern nevada
well we're talking about seasonal
allergies right now it's
spring so it's mainly trees and grasses
so what about those symptoms that we see
what are the most common symptoms
the most common symptoms of allergies
will affect your nose eyes and
throat in the nose it will be stuffy
itchy sneezy
runny nose drainage on the back of your
throat itchy watery red eyes and
clearing your throat frequently those
are the most common symptoms
i know a thing or two about those
symptoms and what can you
actually control those things first
there's two ways one is through
medications and one is
non-medications let's through the let's
do the non-medication way first
and that is trying to avoid our
allergens as much as we can
please use air conditioning 24 7 don't
open windows
especially in the early morning hours
when pollen is highest
so if you're going to perform activities
outdoors we would advise that you do it
mainly in the
afternoon or early evenings rather than
in the morning
and if possible try to shake off your
clothes or take a shower right away once
you come in to get a pollen off of you
and off of your pets if you're walking
up
your dog and of course medication wise
if you know
that this is the season for your
allergies take your medications
regularly
and speaking of medications what are
those what are those treatments that you
suggest for allergies
the oral antihistamines are mainly for
itching sneezing
runny nose itchy watery eyes but
if for if your main problem is the
stuffiness and the drainage on the back
of your throat
the nose sprays specifically nasal
steroids and nasal antihistamines
will be more effective um so let's
switch gears now and talk about asthma
if you have allergies you are three
times more than likely to develop asthma
at any time
in your life now asthma uh will
will be exacerbated will be triggered by
certain things but not caused by certain
things it's caused by allergies mainly
but it can be triggered by things like
vigorous activity
being sick being exposed to some
irritants like smoke or
campfires or being exposed to the things
that you're allergic to
and treatment wise there's two
classifications of medications
one is a rescue inhaler that you take
only when you're having a problem
that's what we call a rescue medication
but if you're needing to use your rescue
medication more than twice a week or if
your asthma is really impacting in your
quality of life
then you need to be on a daily
controller preventive medication it's
very important for a person with
asthma to know what
his or her triggers are so you can be
one step ahead
and your allergist and your doctor could
tell you what are the things that you
can do
to prevent that attack from turning into
a severe attack needing steroids or
hospitalization or er visit all right
optimcare lung and allergy care has
locations across southern nevada just
call 702-724-8844
we'll be right